we are back thank you for joining us I'm
incredibly excited for the next guests
especially in this culture we've talked
about this where you have kids online
there is such a generational gap in the
access of information and it's it's
never been more apparent than with
pornography this guy has actually talked
about it written the book on it your
brain on porn your brain on porn calm
mr. Gary Wilson thank you so much for
coming on hey my pleasure
so okay Gary firstly explain to us what
was it that got you into I guess
studying porn or or sort of getting this
message out there it seems like there's
got to be a story behind that there's a
story but it's rather screen so i'm i
was anatomy and physiology teacher for
many years i met my wife and we started
to write books about the neurobiology of
sex love and bonding and that was about
15 years ago and she had a website and
we had articles up there which had the
words orgasm ejaculation dopamine
addiction because those are related to
bonding and love and sex now about nine
years ago maybe was 10 years ago guy
starts showing up on her website forum
which had nothing to do with porn it was
about relationships and started to post
and say hey I'm addicted to porn and my
penis doesn't work then you help us okay
cheap and she's like what are you doing
here
well Google as it is but the words and
those articles together which brought
them there and then put the post that
they had put those out there brought
more guys there and then over the next
few years it became sort of a porn
recovery form and these were older guys
when I say older guys they were in their
30s 40s and they had high-speed internet
before anyone else but they were
complaining about sexual dysfunctions
well around 2009 we started to write
articles on Psychology Today about these
amazing benefits that they started to
experience because we tried to get to
work word out because it seems like
there was a huge gap between what was
really happening and what was going on
in these guys live
so that brought a whole lot more guys
and my wife that you got to create a
separate website I created your brain um
born calm about four years ago and then
that blew up and I followed all the
links to it back to the original post I
thought how busy so let me ask you real
quick is your background I guess at all
sort of psychology or psychiatry or was
it just something you fell in
accidentally in theology physiology okay
okay so this is just something you came
into because yeah like I guess business
owners in a lot of ways you know you saw
a need and and we're meeting a demand
now right away before your critics come
out and say this is just you know
they've always said this to people
who've ever been to centers of the
pornography industry this is just some
crazy right-wing Christian extremist
who's trying to scare your kids that
that's not really the case here no I'm
very far left liberal who's not
religious and never been a Christian
neither as my wife or my parents and my
grandparents so nope
I wanted nothing to do with this and I
we just felt compelled because there was
this blind spot and when you have guys
writing you and telling you that they're
suicidal because their penises don't
work and they're not getting good
information and the urologist they're
saying you know just take some viagra
there's nothing we can do we felt
compelled but we did write about it
right no it's it's incredible and there
are a few things that I've seen you
mentioned before in other interviews and
obviously in your book one of them was
you talked about which to me was just
fascinating I don't have the exact
number so I'm sure you've got this
you're like the computer wore tennis
shoes I've seen your interviews and TED
Talks there's a generation of young men
who have had a certain amount of sexual
experiences you've said you never did in
a thousands you know sexual experiences
who for the first time have had all of
these experiences without any actual
sexual interaction with another human
being right what was that number I don't
know because there's no numbers to it
in terms I read something I don't know I
could be misquoting where you talked
about how there's a point now where you
have kids who
think it was a certain percentage aren't
even actually interested in real sexual
interaction and many of them have
certain sexual experiences based you
know with pornography but no actual
sexual interaction and there was a
number in there that I remember just
shocked me so I'm I'm not pulling it out
of nowhere there was a number that
shocked about no I think what you're
saying is you're looking at Japan so
Japan had a number thirty six percent of
men young men ages 16 to 19 had
absolutely no interest in sex and that
number doubled from 2008 so we see a
tremendous rise in Japanese young men
who had technology ahead of the game and
they are you know pay with corn over
there and it's just unfathomable to me
that a teenage guy would have no
interest yeah to me either I mean I'll
tell you what as a Christian
conservative it was like a full-time job
just thinking about it it was exhausting
I always tell women when they go then
all you guys think about well from about
age 14 through you know 20 yes literally
it is pretty fascinating again that
you're sort of a liberal you know not
interested in religion you really make
the argument right in the book leagues
it that the physiological arguments the
arguments about about dopamine receptors
and the way you know neuro chemistry is
affected have you met a lot of pushback
before we get into that which we'll get
into the next segment have you gotten a
lot of pushback from either the porn
industry or other so-called progressives
got no pushback whatsoever from the porn
industry got some pushback from some
academic sexologist who don't like the
idea that you can suggest that porn use
may cause some problems
so there's right well vocal groups of
technologists and academics arts
colleges who do push back quite a bit
yeah well I even read something in the
Atlantic where they talked about and
we'll get into the studies just because
we have to take a break relatively soon
here and there's a lot of data to get
into but I will say I'm surprised that
you say that about the adult film
industry because I have seen videos and
and posts online of people saying you
know online porn is is healthy and don't
believe the fear mongers here who are
trying to scare
you out of it but maybe they're just not
emailing you directly well I just think
that comes from people who are
progressive or even Christians or
whatever and then just like to use porn
and they're mixing up what occurred in
the 70s where you're looking at a still
picture and you're a 14-year old and you
can use your imagination all you can
think about it right-click on one second
hold that thought with to go to this
break and we will be right back ladder
with Crowder we are back with Gary
Wilson author of your brain on porn or
go to the website your brain on porn
calm it's not that kind of website Gary
Wilson thanks for being back now before
we left you were about to get into some
some information here which I also find
fascinating listen I I'm always pretty
straightforward I'm a more right-leaning
guy and personally I'm a Christian so
obviously Christians have talked about
for a long time how pornography can be
harmful to one sex life namely because
it creates unrealistic expectations of
sex and you know Christians believe it's
something that should be should be kept
between a husband and a wife now I know
that's not necessarily a contention with
this book but you do talk about how porn
has changed in the landscape of the
internet like you said where there was
at one point the mild pornography
you know required the use of your
imagination whereas now that's not the
case and you even sort of draw some
parallels I remember with Facebook and
this sort of instant gratification
addiction of the internet tell us a bit
about that I find it fascinating well
you know you think about it we had
pictures and words around for a long
time but all of a sudden you see this
entire generation stuck with their
iPhones clicking on pictures and words
and videos so what makes it so
fascinating is the delivery system the
internet what the internet does is it
takes advantage of the innate mechanisms
that are pretty much there in the reward
centers of a mammal and the first one is
novelty the reward center lights up with
dopamine for such things as food and sex
and achievement but also for novelty
anything new grabs the attention and you
get little bursts of dopamine that make
you want to go for it right so of course
the Internet you can just click click
click endlessly and keep your dope
spiking forever but here's what's
interesting is not only with internet
porn do we have endless novelty
available but we have nature's highest
reward of dopamine which is sexual
stimulation and measures number one
priority which is reproduction then you
combine it with other things that raise
dopamine in animals and that such things
as shock or surprise or even anxiety
those things also raise dopamine and
what not shocking or surprising or even
anxiety filling when it comes to some of
this hardcore pornography filter it
really can't trap that's even shocking
just reading you know the transcripts
from dick Morris's fetishes so I can
imagine when you're actually seeing
something that's that depraved on camera
yeah and I think I mentioned too I've
heard you mention it I want to clarify
for the listener not only novelty but
specifically with dopamine you know
novelty you included the exceeding of
expectations you know which basically
happens all the time online right if I
say hey I want to research I don't know
coffee mugs in World War two boom
there's more than I could ever read on
coffee mugs in World War two in a
lifetime right and that causes a spike
in dopamine and you're combining that
with sex yeah isn't necessarily food
because you can keep eating and you're
just like oh I don't want to eat anymore
right so that your dopamine is going
down what makes it go up is violation of
expectations there you go we use regular
terms like shock surprise anxiety the
unexpected that's what makes bungee
jumping or horror films exciting sure
cuz they shocked us so that is set up in
all mammals to raise dopamine and that
means that it's like oh this is more
than what I expected this is more this
is right I was just looking for a guy
and a girl having a good time and it
involves two midgets a tricycle and a
parent what happened here you know
they're getting interested as the
hormones come up and they put in boobs
and not boobs come up oh my god that's
crazy stuff that isn't even
nice thumbs up and it's videos which
videos are far more engaging than
pictures and the other thing to know
about videos is they actually co-op and
replace imagination in young man right
well one thing - I will say this you
know as someone who I mean people will
be watching this interview right here on
YouTube we do it to rest truly on radio
we podcast but we get on YouTube right
so let me give you an idea here people
watch my videos on average for over four
minutes so the average retention rate is
62% because they have some longer videos
right that with YouTube is an incredible
retention rate if you're keeping people
past 30 or 40 percent of a video it's
considered amazing and that allows
you're gonna premium advertising revenue
I'm getting a little technical here but
the reason I say that is because you
know my living' depends on creating
things that are quick interesting enough
and the rule of thumb is always shorter
shorter shorter because people's
attention spans have noticeably I mean
they're measurable shorter than before
and I know that applies to YouTube right
but I don't have the data or analytics
does that apply to pornography sites do
they have to create more bang for your
buck in the shortest amount of time
which would seem to lend itself to like
you said a little little more shocking
in a little less time right yeah
absolutely look at what changed
everything changed in 2006 with the
invention of YouTube and then that
created tube sites and often you've have
in the sidebars on a porn site you have
little three minute clips and so you can
just go from three minutes clip the
three minute clip but most guys describe
that they can't even laugh through the
three minute clips they're bored so
they'll go to the next one the next one
and then eventually what came up we're
compilation videos where you just have
four or five seconds of a bunch of
orgasms and ejaculations lined up and
people just watch those and on in gosh
and I don't know if we can say that on
air just be careful cuz the FCC does
monitor this but I think it's medical so
we'll clear it it's medical i'ma just
wear your lab coat and it's fine so uh
no I sorry I didn't why I didn't want to
interrupt your point bells going oh gosh
I don't know I don't know which words we
can't I think this is uncharted
territory it's the same reason you know
a lot of people are afraid of
of talking about this on traditional
content so there you go there's the
irony right the problem comes with new
media and the problem comes with the
Internet and instant gratification but
on the flip side you also have a form
and you get to bypass you know the media
filters who might not necessarily agree
with your viewpoint right you know and
here's the thing about when you're
you're watching something so people talk
about dopamine and I talk about dopamine
and how its raised but what's the end
result of dopamine dopamine they're two
ryr into your brain so that you will
repeat that behavior because it thinks
that behavior is further your survival
or the survival of your genes so it
thinks that in some level that you are
actually impregnating a real person but
it's wiring in all the associations with
that experience while you're watching
porn but what does that mean to a young
guy that means to a young guy that is
wiring and not touch and being touched
and real interaction but it's wiring and
sitting being a Boyar clicking from
seeing design controlling your dopamine
with a mouse shock the prize multiple
tabs that's what you're training your
brain to become sexually aroused -
because that's what dopamine telling ya
around - this so that you will repeat
this it's like a Hitchcock film you're
breeding a bunch of kids who are sitting
there with binoculars going and looking
at you through the window put your foot
in his mouth literally you know it's
fascinating that you talk about that
because I I mean I'm sure there was some
of that right even when people were
looking at a dirty magazine under a mat
you know we didn't have the same data
though you know it's the same reason we
talk about this right now you're really
talking about an evolution of human
consumption of information since 2006 I
mean that's the number you just through
fascinating is that that everything has
changed since 2006 we don't really have
and that's the the criticism I've seen
sort of leveled against you is people
say well a lot of it is hypothetical
because we don't really have enough
numbers back yet because the generation
who grew up on instant porn as much as
they want they're not really adults with
families of their own yet
well here's the deal so let's look at
the actual data so there are 95 brain
studies on internet addiction brain
studies all 95 showed the same brain
changes as seen in drug addicts
what does that tell us that tells us
that audio visual simulation when done
in excess can cause the same brain
changes as drug addiction so that's not
arguable now that in the last year
there's been 3 brain studies on porn
users guess what those three found the
same brain changes that occur with those
who have drug addiction is also found in
both of those studies that the more porn
use the left arousal to sexual images
and in one of the studies 60% of the
subjects who were born addicted had
trouble getting erections with real
people but not with porn so that's three
for three so in fact all the actual hard
evidence is pointing in one direction
hard evidence it's ironic because there
is none listen I'm sorry come on you
walked right into it you're the
physiologist I'm the comic hack that is
fascinating to me and and I know you you
make the argument that it's almost a
public health issue I don't necessarily
want to get to the legislative component
of this because I'm more so interested
in just a physiological ramification so
let me ask you this okay what's the
endgame wit for layman's out there for
someone someone's brain right who's
grown up let's say from they were 12 in
2006 when all of us porn became
instantaneous right just completely
readily available what's the endgame in
their brain where they end up if they're
watching porn and click click clip every
day versus someone from the previous
generation who didn't have access to
that things that go on in the brain what
you don't even have to have addiction
with and that sexual conditioning you
can look at sexual conditioning in two
ways one as a young man you're
conditioning your sexual arousal to
sitting and clicking and being a Boyar
or at the young men you're conditioning
your sexual arousal to certain acts so
those acts you may want to replay out in
real life because that's what you've
masturbated to for the last five years
before
you actually had a date with a girl so
those two things are occurring one study
was done and it's found a tremendous
increase in anal sex and when it asks
these young people 16 to 18 why they
were doing it
neither the male some of the females
were sure except they both pointed to
porn and they also neither the male sort
of females enjoyed it but they felt
compelled to do it because they thought
that's what they're supposed to do
that's sexual conditioning too so it's
almost like you know hey smoke the
cigarette Johnny it'll make you cool
only it's uh hey let's do page 85 for
this weird sex book or page 50 or page
56 of porn tube it's almost like a cyber
peer pressure that people aren't even
realizing yes because the guys are
exchanging that's cool they're talking
about it and they're watching it and
they think it's normal because they're
watching real people have real sex and
supposedly real orgasms and they think
that this is the way it's done because
this is all they know this is what they
do for years wow that is pretty and I
know I keep saying this it's it's insane
to really think about that's going to be
an entire generation of young men I mean
what's that going to cause you know in
the workplace what's that going to cause
I mean think about this in the year 2000
42 the guy who's running for president
had access to all of this porn and you
know most likely was at the very least
dabbling unless he was in a church youth
group think about that these people are
gonna be building our planes and leading
our countries that's messed up well you
know you know you're talking about
what's it like for young guys well
here's a little bit of information so a
lot of the guys only stop when they have
porn induced erectile dysfunction
Graeme what we've seen is that the older
guys in their forties and fifties can
often recover erectile function hey Gary
and I hold you on for next segment
because I know that's gonna take a
little bit of time and I've read that
part in your book it's fascinating Gary
Wilson we'll be right back
ladder with Crowder right back in
wasting no time because right before the
break the last word was erectile
dysfunction BAM Gary Wilson of your
brain on porn calm is back with a scary
please finish the thought that you had
before I so rudely had to take us to
break
yeah what I was trying to say is that
the the older man who developed a
reptile dysfunction it's an interesting
thing first most of them had no problems
they've been using corn for 30 years but
they didn't develop the records of
function until after the advent of tube
sites they said that was the big
game-changer then they would heal in
about six to eight weeks maybe back
functioning fine strong as ever
now over the last two to four years
we've seen young guys showing up in
their twenties sometimes in their teens
with chronic erectile dysfunction and
it's taking them from six to twelve
months sometimes two years to recover
and even when they're recovered they're
still not completely solid so it's
taking them so much longer even though
they're younger healthier have more
testosterone and just have better
everything
yep that's taking them longer this shows
you the power of conditioning your
sexual response during adolescence when
the brain is highly malleable and when
you're pruning down all these nerve
connections to rewire yourself to your
sexual environment and that's what
they're doing and their sexual
environment is sitting and watching porn
okay let me ask you this because again
you said you've not gotten pushed back
from the adult film industry I've seen
some offline I have I have maybe they're
just not emailing you or maybe you have
them on block because you have an
incredible spam filter that filters out
anything poorni but they argue right
this is fear-mongering that it's
perfectly fine and porn can and should
be used in a healthful way no I know
where I line up on that but you as
someone who is does not have I guess a
moral dog in the fight oh you know do
you think there is a way for porn to be
used healthily should that be encouraged
or do you think it's just a something
that should be avoided for for young men
well you know
I mean if young guys are looking at new
pictures or something like that
occasionally that might not be a problem
but when you start watching videos it
could be a problem okay but here's the
deal is it's not I mean this is a hard
subject it's hard for me to describe
what's really going on it's so much
different now with the advent of the
Internet even with nude pictures we've
had young guys who developed erectile
dysfunction while using nude pictures
but they would go through about a
thousand or 2,000 of them in one
masturbation session so you can't match
that type of novelty in real life or in
using magazines so the problem becomes
you're training your brain to be a
lawyer now your question was can it be
used healthfully I don't know if it can
be used healthily but I guess it's about
what are your goals if your goals are to
become really excited with a real
partner then perhaps you want to avoid
porn if your goal is to just become
really excited no matter what then you
could use for and become excited that my
goal is to become excited with a real
partner how dare you I know how dare you
pass judgment on this generation you're
like that you're like that old man who
just yells the kids in the street turn
down your boom box it's not real music
so that's what you've become right
you walked a mile in the snow to school
both ways and when you got to school
there was an actual physical naked lady
how dare you know it is you know and
this and this is where it comes from
listen you know as as Christians which I
am there are certain spiritual truths
which we hold to be self-evident which a
lot of times you see manifesting itself
in a way physically here you know for
example there are a lot of things you
know you probably shouldn't eat a ton of
shellfish you know watching a lot of
porn and having a lot of her miss fewest
sex could probably be bad for you and I
don't think anyone argues with it so I
think there's a lot of ways for people
to find common ground I had no idea that
you were a liberal mr. Wilson how I you
know
time now that I know this beer liberal
oh you're a beer liberal well you know
actually the beer severe about the
opposite ended you right well you know
we had an actual terrorist on this show
if you've followed anything that we've
done Imam Xiao tree so at least you got
that going for you you're not quite a
terrorist well good that you're
correlating Paris with liberals I like
that of course I do I'm very at least
you guys tolerate it you know I figure
you guys are all in cahoots you have a
secret meeting behind our back no but
listen it's it's funny to hear that
because a lot of people listen you're
not necessarily making a brand new
argument right Gary there have been a
lot of people more so we would say you
know on the right a lot of Christians
who have talked about this and maybe
ever necessarily had the same data to
back it up but I see you agreeing with a
lot of those people even though you come
in at opposite sides of the political
spectrum so there are issues like this
where I think people can just look at
the data we have available to us the
evidence and say hey you know what we
can agree this is something I don't
necessarily know through legislation but
we should be joining hands here and and
making people aware of a real problem
now do you actually go as far as
considering this a public health issue
that would require some kind of
government intervention or you is your
goal just to build awareness you know in
a personal level my goal is to build
awareness
I don't like government intervention so
we can agree on that well the liberal
get out of here i hey i'm a really nice
try and so i think what needs to be done
is we always talk about education but
then people talk about sex education if
we look at sex education you know
whatever it is what's missing in sex
education is education about
neuroplasticity without the reward
circuit and how it is very vulnerable to
over stimulation and how you can
actually alter perhaps your sexual to
deck three your sexual tapes your sexual
desires by over stimulating it with a
new stimulus that never existed before
high-speed internet porn that's what i
think should be in the sex education
that isn't in there today you know what
you're gonna hate to hear
you know who's going to be immune to
this are those gun-toting rednecks out
in the boonies because they're still
dealing with dial-up so they're the only
people who will be immune to this
absolute plague of high-speed
pornography how's that for irony mr.
Wilson and guess what I don't mind
people owning gun I know well you know I
listen I think I truly believe listen
that we agree on more than we disagree
we just had lyric Keith on last week who
you may or may not know we both share a
disdain for vegans but she also believes
that humans are you know a plague on the
earth and that we need to reduce
population and you know the animals
should rule all kind of deal very very
sweet lady but I listen we agree on a
lot and I find your book fascinating
your writing is is incredible on this
subject and actually I found you through
Brett McKay over there at Art of
Manliness I think he used you as a
reference so yeah yeah and he's actually
you know again he would be in a
different side of the political spectrum
than either of us much more of a
moderate you know I'm to the right of
Attila the Hun I'm sure to someone like
you where can people go to find out more
about you and then I want you to have
the last word here Gary what is the big
takeaway you want for people if they're
hearing this interview well you can just
put in your brain Tom Horne calm you'll
go to my side it's the free side has
lots of stuff on it have some videos and
you can buy a book if you want to and
the proceeds of the book are earmarked
towards education and research and the
take away from this is that a lot of
young men do not know that they're
effective said a lot of old men do not
know they're affected until they remove
porn use take it away for a couple of
months maybe three months and then see
if it changes for you see if you have
more sexual arousal real partners your
outlook changes maybe social anxiety
goes away maybe depression lessons take
application from porn use and then make
the judgment about whether corns
affecting you that would be my challenge
to your listener and a perfectly
sensible challenge that I think is
easier said than done for many of the
sticky disgusting 14-year old listening
to this and there
caste catcher but Gary Wilson thank you
so much brother and really we hope to
have you back liberal or not okay thanks
you have a good one hope you enjoyed
that video and learn something I know
I'm gonna cancel my order for the
left-handed Mouse and if you want to
watch this video next to me or subscribe
it's free so I guess it's a no-lose